[Musik]
[Applaus]
der afrikanische sonnenaufgang und
jungen der sich unschlagbar
bild gemalt mit afrikanischen summen und
gegangen dieser war mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat und jungen weil das
ganze spiel im kopf verankert und wollen
wir jetzt schon acht jahre sind das
zentrum jedes mal im team
und jedes mal mit zahlreichen verdrahtet
vergleiche mit dem shanty chor gesungen
und begann als ich es wurden wird er
nach unsere anliegen schönheit
aber der alltag im paradies ist auch
unberechenbar
christians frau mischa ist notärztin bei
der okavango air rescue ihr tag beginnt
ganz anders wir sind heute morgen um
halb sieben aus dem bett berufen worden
für einen möglichen helikoptereinsatz im
delta wo sich ein kleines mädchen
verletzt hat am bein und der vater
besteht darauf dass ein arztes anschaut
wir haben dann gesagt okay wir können
sofort fliegen um einen
kostenvoranschlag gemacht weil es kein
lebensbedrohlicher notfall ist und haben
jetzt das ist auf die uhr gucken
zwei stunden später das okay bekommen
wir dürfen kommen aber nicht jetzt weil
die gäste gehen jetzt auf einen game
drive und es wäre recht wenn wir gegen
12 uhr dort landen würden
[Musik]
im okawango delta in botswana können
vermögende touristen aus aller welt eine
vielzahl an wilden tieren beobachten
game drives heißen die safari fahrten in
gesicherten fahrzeugen
[Musik]
wenn diese gäste nach der schweizer
rettungsschirm anrufen weiß ja nie genau
was sie erwartet eine lebensbedrohliche
verletzung oder eine bagatelle
im mittleren westen der usa ist tornado
saison seit einer woche fahren die
fribourger dominik und sascha durch das
große land jagen gewitterzellen und
wollen unbedingt einen tornado vor ihre
fotolinse bekommen physiklehrer dominik
hat ein gewitter entdeckt dass es in
sich hat das ist klar vor ihren augen
entwickelt sich die perfekte
ausgangslage für einen tornado
und das nur ein paar kilometer entfernt
die beiden können es nicht glauben das
ist unglaublich dass erlöst vorraum
studiums jetzt nur keine zeit verlieren
während sascha das mietauto bereit macht
prüft dominique was seine konkurrenten
die professionellen storm chaser
vorhaben aber dass die bereits seit über
unterwegs
und das geht im mit vfl westercelle
haben ist am richtigen ort omv stiegen
in der marine
und ich hoffe ich dass nichts belegt
dass tornado jagen ist in den usa
volkssport meteorologen hobby fotografen
journalisten und ganze busladungen von
touristen
alle wollen den nervenkitzel eines
möglichst mächtigen tornados hautnah
miterleben
die beiden schweizer halten sich von der
masse fern
sie wollen ihren eigenen tornado finden
und das mit mainstream ein entlang
gleichwertige genommen so dass ich mir
hier gut sehr gut positioniert worden
was das teil macht das der tornado
sonntagmorgen in osttimor südostasien
daniel moser und seine familie widmen
diese zeit gott in der hauskirche
gemeinsam mit freunden vater ich bin
sehr dankbar dass sich vater nennen darf
dankbar dass du mir ein guter vater bist
und ich mit dir in einer beziehung sein
darf es ist wunderbar dass du jeden
akzeptierst auch mich so wie ich bin
ich musste nichts beweisen sondern kann
immer zu dir kommen
danke dass du heute für uns da bist
armen ganzen haus wo man bezweckt das
praktiziert und mache darüber können wir
sicherlich anders mclaren ist vereint
danke das ist richtig gedanken hängen
dass mir alle tvw gut dass man alles
immer metris klopeiner see und quasi was
was mir gefällt es bringe und das ist
kein teil von dann ist das man aber wie
realisierte schwächlinge sie untergrabe
[Musik]
daniel ist überzeugter christ vor acht
jahren hatte er ein erlebnis das sein
leben für immer verändert hat
damals war er fallschirmaufklärer für
die schweizer armee flog bin eben ein
flugzeug im cockpit ist weil ich ihn
töten will kocht wirklich nicht
zugeschrieben ruf und zu ihm nach links
und rechts kurve und mich tatsächlich
die woche nach zürich geflogen und die
da momentan die wiener stimmt das war
nicht wie vorher und nachher nehmen
elektrisch winterstimmung mit clotted
stoff lüge und wertstoffe mehr flüge die
zwei fragen ewigkeit und die akustiker
dass für die zeit danach sowie daniel
pilot bei der mission aviation
fellowship einer christlichen
hilfsorganisation
seit vier jahren lebt er ein leben als
missionar ich wollte weg von mir ist es
einfach mit globus lava und das ganz
verschieden jahr bin ich recht sich
globus eine schwache auftritte so ganz
praktisch flickr oder was eigentlich
beginnen
der inselstaat osttimor liegt in
südostasien nördlich von australien
er ist nur ein drittel so groß wie die
schweiz und hat gut eine million
einwohner
täglich ist daniel mit der realität im
dritten land der welt konfrontiert
seine arbeit ist hier bitter nötig ein
neugeborenes hat zu wenig blut es muss
so schnell wie möglich ins krankenhaus
der hauptstadt dili gebracht werden
ein rettungswagen braucht über die
bergstraßen drei bis vier stunden
der flug wird keine 30 minuten dauern
diese zeit entscheidet oft über leben
und tod
die kleinen dürfen
osttimor ist dringend auf ausländische
hilfsorganisationen angewiesen
das land ist erst seit 2002 eigenständig
vieles funktioniert noch nicht so wie es
sollte
[Musik]
am flughafen sollte das baby möglichst
schnell ins krankenhaus transportiert
werden
aber der krankenwagen ist noch nicht da
wenn diabetes regen habe ja auch wenn
ich denn mit der ambulanz ist es schon
mein gesteht sie einfach keine fahrer
meint christian polanc kaputt und ja
dritte sich besondere mühe macht
[Musik]
komm endlich daniel kann den kleinen
patienten den rettungssanitätern
übergeben
jetzt erheben
ich habe nicht über das schicksal
informiert und interessiert und autos
wer die tour geht und sie erfordert der
versuche irgendwie abschließt
merlot am fuße der anden gestern
überquerte der ostschweizer stephan
eberle mit seinem ballon die
gebirgskette auf 7000 meter höhe
heute soll es entspannt dazu und her
gehen mit einer fahrt über das
weinanbaugebiet von mendoza
[Musik]
am mittag jetzt plötzlich recht winker
thermisch und so wernicke zwei
halbfinals zweimal am tag
stefan ist einer der weltbesten piloten
aber die verhältnisse in den bergen
argentiniens sind nicht zu vergleichen
mit dem wind in den schweizer alpen
hier kreuzen sich verschiedene zug winde
ab einer gewissen höhe kann das
gefährlich werden
er stand während starker dreifache
befürchten kunden verlaufen
[Musik]
täglich sterben
sie haben jetzt 16 7
so will ab anfang juni hatte gross je
die schweiz mit dem ball und das haben
extrem viel ballonfahrer kann also den
übrigen gebieten ist es hat einfach
optimal zum war schon mit 67 ist für
mich lag sie mit 16 moral befangen
ballonfahrer das auch mit bronze
min endlich unterstützt der in dem buch
zeigt ja aber interviews machen den
machbar meint uhr aufbau moment als lang
an der natürlich mühsam und hat
erzeugten verkaufen und so war das schon
im schulalter geld verdienen so konnte
stefan seinen traum verwirklichen
mit 16 hat er seinen ersten ball
eingekauft bis heute hat er über 2000
fahrten gemacht ist siebenfacher
schweizer meister und vierfacher
europameister geworden
faszination ich genau die gleiche wir
als kleine burg mit dem spiel vom wind
mit der natur verbunden
die anden erzeugen ab einer gewissen
höhe wind wirbel die den ballon
ordentlich zusetzen können stefan weiß
nicht in welcher höhe die turbulenzen
auftauchen und wie stark sie sein werden
wie hoch sie mir 2006
das ganze momentum gemütlich werden
[Musik]
jonas langenecker hat einen großen traum
er will schweizer meister im
segelkunstflug werden seit er mit 15 zum
ersten mal in einem segelflugzeug saß
lässt ihn diese art des fliegens nicht
mehr los naja es fast nicht glauben
eigentlich ja ich weiss nicht werden wir
wohl angefangen hätten zu denen ich sie
sind glied das ist flüge und wenn wir
dann einfach wieder mal einen himmel
wirkt und die wirklich seht ich glaube
dann wird man merken immer wieder in den
flügeln und eigentlich tanz
[Musik]
jonas fährt fast jedes wochenende auf
den flugplatz um zu trainieren
heute kann der 25-jährige ein
großzügiges erbe antreten
jonas bekommt einen alten wohnwagen
direkt beim flugplatz amlikon geschenkt
jetzt kann der wahl zürcher auch hier
wohnen und übernachten wenn er an den
wochenenden für die
schweizermeisterschaft im segelkunstflug
trainiert und ich habe mir gebracht
auf dem flugplatz schwimmer sollen
schöne wohnlage hätte sicherlich
errichten
eigentlich lebt jonas mit seiner
freundin anna im zürcherischen
effretikon anna unterstützt ihren freund
bei seinem aufwendigen hobby vor allem
an den wochenenden muss sie aber oft auf
ihn verzichten
denken
die jung flieger sind eine
eingeschworene gemeinschaft die jonas
extrem wichtig ist hier fühlt er sich
zuhause
trotz aller geselligkeit in jonas steckt
ein ehrgeiziger pilot an der
schweizermeisterschaft in einer woche
will er beweisen dass er sich
weiterentwickelt hat
er wagt den großen sprung in die höchste
kategorie unlimited bis ein anruf sein
großes ziel zunichte macht der
organisator teilt ihm mit dass die
kategorie an limited in diesem jahr
nicht durchgeführt werden kann sich so
dass man sich der einzig teilnehmen ob
ich nicht anbietet wenn ich jetzt höre
die unlimited schweizer meister oder ein
harter schlag für jonas scheinbar
vergeblich hat er sich drei monate lang
vorbereitet
bei einer extra trainiert ist dafür
angemietet und würde gern die zeiger
wenig gehabt haben und auch einem jahr
nur gut dass es auch wirklich ruhig
[Musik]
die tornado jäger dominik und sascha
hingegen sind ihrem ziel näher eine
gewitterzelle baut sich auf auch bei den
anderen sturmjäger herrschen und
plötzlich aufbruchstimmung beim usv und
dies mit haut es mich immer voller zu
fuß unterwegs und ähnliche vorfälle
während die anderen tornado jäger auf
ein gewitter im norden setzen fahren die
zwei schweizer auswärts
ballaballa
jetzt geht es nur noch darum rechtzeitig
am richtigen ort zu sein
dabei verletzte straße
vermutlich zeit zu verschaffen damit sie
hier
der spannende moment zum ganzen chasing
schafften das muslim
während seine frau michelle einen
medizinischen einsatz fliegt fährt
christian gross zu einem schulhaus
mitten im delta air und micha haben das
projekt gemeinsam geplant und bauen
lassen
hier sollen schon bald die kinder der
umliegenden farmen zur schule gehen das
einzugsgebiet beträgt mehrere dutzend
kilometer großen gemeinschaftsraum und
testrunde klassenzimmer als das
obligatorische schule in botswana
nur haben die schweizer noch keine
lehrer gefunden die hier unterrichten
wollen solange die gebäude noch leer
stehen machen sich die wildtiere gerne
an den sträuchern zu schaffen mit seiner
okawango air rescue hat christian ein
erfolgreiches unternehmen aufgebaut
nun will er der bevölkerung von botswana
etwas zurückgeben mehr an selbe politik
in alle da seid natürlich frostig spart
und einer cross cult vielleicht noch
einmal große floor kann man
schwierigkeiten kam mit der lastwagen
die wasserlöcher turi2 und wir haben ein
paar hunderttausend franken luft für für
den transport und die 230 franken für
materialien und für die waage
wer hier draußen im busch auf etwas
wartet braucht geduld
aber christian ist zuversichtlich dass
die lehrer schon bald gefunden werden
und der schulbetrieb beginnen kann
[Musik]
ein paar kilometer von austrias
hauptstadt entfernt arbeitet der ora
moser die frau von missions- pilot
daniel kommt alle zwei wochen hierher
sie hat eine ausbildung als
heilpädagogin und hilft menschen mit
einem handicap von eli begleitet sie zur
arbeit behindert nicht so wichtig dass
hier und da vor ihr schaffte die machen
es immer die beste und die glaubt
braucht ist derjenigen und das ist gut
aber die trainer noch lebt ist mit gang
und dass ich so glaube ich diese stunden
im heim für behinderte bedeuten
demografie sie genießt die abwechslung
zu hause ist sie mit eli oft allein
deborah arbeitet ehrenamtlich
sie hat kein arbeitsvisum für osttimor
b
[Applaus]
wie ist eine komische das war schweiz
schaffe tag letter ist natürlich
verdammt
[Musik]
seit vier jahren leben deborah und
daniel in osttimor in einer kultur die
ihnen zu beginn völlig fremd war die
moral sind wo ich hoffe dass sie immer
schlechtere osttimor hat sich 2002 in
einem unabhängigkeitskrieg von
indonesien getrennt die folgen dieses
krieges sind bis heute spürbar als
sicheres entwicklungsland es wird
oftmals betitelt außerdem stellen sie
doch stets der mensch hat die maus im
westen wo man alles macht für das ist
man austria hause drückt es die
bevölkerung und vertrauen das mir dran
blieb aber das geht den menschen wo
nicht
unser unterricht ist definitiv sache
vorher
bis 11 das sitzt
[Musik]
der sohn von deborah und daniel wächst
in osttimor auf und der kleine
blondschopf fällt hier auf die heads
reiber und irgendwie dafür jedoch
erstaunt vor
[Musik]
in botswana ist mischa unterwegs zu
einem medizinischen einsatz
sie wurde in eine safari lodge im
okawango delta gerufen
hier soll sich das kind amerikanischer
touristen am bein verletzt haben wie
schlimm die verletzung ist weist die
notfallärzte nicht er weiß es nicht ich
weiß es nicht wir fahren jetzt zu
irgendeinem patienten und schau mal vor
da was machen können wie hier nahe zu
kommen
[Musik]
der ranger bringt mischa und ihr team in
dieser phase lodge ein luxus hotel
mitten im naturreservat hallo ich bin dr
wir haben die wunde jetzt jeden tag
gereinigt und versorgt und das war nicht
genug
ich habe meinem doktor zu hause ein bild
geschickt und er hat gemeint es wäre
besser wenn man es anschaut und du bist
die arme verletzte ich denke wir gehen
mal rein und schauen uns das an die bein
verletzung ist nichts schlimmes zur
sicherheit will mischa dem mädchen aber
eine infusion mit antibiotika liegen
na komm jetzt so einfach darüber
das ist schon vorbei hast du das
überlebt schon fertig
die sache ist schnell erledigt und das
team der okavango air rescue bett für
seinen einsatz mit seltenen besuch
belohnt
[Musik]
elefanten trauen sich nicht oft so nah
an eine safari lodge heran
[Musik]
und kurz darauf geht es auch schon
wieder zurück zum helikopter
es soll jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben gewesen aber ich bin recht
optimistisch dass das wieder gut kommt
viele kleine wunden starten so und
werden dann zum großen desaster und
enden manchmal auf der intensivstation
stephan und sein team sind derweilen in
ein paar heftige turbulenzen geraten
die unvorhersehbaren zug winde über der
argentinischen hochebene machen dem
erfahrenen piloten zu schaffen
ich glaube ich glaube hier bleibt
mit einer schönen situation und darin
macht dann immer so also wir wählen noch
hatte und die jetzt spürt die wellen
römer und je nachdem wie stark sie sind
[Musik]
stefan ist als erster gestartet jetzt
kann er seine kollegen vor den
turbulenzen waren
jetzt können wir die schöne ballonfahrt
weiter genießen
das mag ich nicht so
[Musik]
ola
die fahrt über das weinanbaugebiet von
mendoza war die zweite etappe dieser
expedition
[Musik]
der höhepunkt der reise steht stefan
aber noch bevor
morgen will er vom balkon aus die totale
sonnenfinsternis über argentinien
beobachten
im us-bundesstaat texas geht es nicht so
beschaulich zu und her
die tornado jäger jagen mit 130
stundenkilometern einer gewitterzelle
hinterher
dominique muss sich entscheiden welche
gewitterzelle er weiter verfolgt wird
die vorsicht
hauzenberg
was die auf das
dann aber waren sehr schönes minute
das ist ja jetzt links peter hlinka
beratung zu bringen
jetzt wirklich spaß und so noch hat er
heute werden dort
nations links sie das leben hier ist
nicht noch als kunden jetzt linkspartei
und die war einfach und schnell des
vorderen orients
aber nach den vielen kleinen irrwegen
scheint sich der sturm plötzlich in luft
aufgelöst zu haben
der sturm hat bis zum livestream
[Musik]
obwohl die wetterdaten einiges mehr
versprochen hatten bleibt zum schluss
einmal mehr nur ein regenschauer übrig
vielleicht wäre die andere gewitterzelle
doch die bessere wahl gewesen
und jetzt fällt mir ein besseres und
tischen aufgebaut
ich bin ja auch bisher betrieb
unterrichten
[Musik]
mit den jetzt am richtigen ort und der
entscheid und selbstbewusstsein
[Musik]
auch im thurgau ist die stimmung getrübt
wetterlage ist ein hochdruckgebiet mit
zentrum über der ostsee bestimmt heute
das wetter in der schweiz im süden und
in den alpen ist die luftmasse generell
etwas feuchter und labil geschichtete
die winde sind in allen höheren
ausgesprochen schwach vor ein paar tagen
hat jonas erfahren dass er nicht an der
schweizer meisterschaft starten kann
als einziger teilnehmer in der höchsten
kategorie unlimited fehlt ihm die nötige
konkurrenz der 25-jährige ist enttäuscht
ich habe ihm auch geküsst das klappt mit
der teilnehmerzahl
natürlich habe ich will msi mit der
anderen gern wäre natürlich falsch
gesehen oder hitze können aber vor allem
medial das training wille und der
vergleich zu anderen piloten vor allem
sehr stark und aus der traum vom
schweizer meister weil jonas nicht
genügend gegner hat kann er keine titel
gewinnen
drei monate training umsonst die absage
ist auch abends am lagerfeuer das
hauptthema
für mich ist ziel schon wettbewerber zu
können also ich würde jetzt nicht
irgendwie an den wettbewerb auch wenn
ich weiß ich wir durch den gletscher
ich glaube da wir also für mich
persönlich war es jetzt endlich glaubt
denn während dieser motivierte nächste
werkstück jonas hat keine lust an der
meisterschaft teilzunehmen ohne
konkurrenz gibt es für ihn nichts zu
gewinnen
eine teilnahme wäre nicht mehr als ein
training fürs nächste jahr
die infocus druck setzen lassen
mit dem nachteil dass jetzt hat er jetzt
allein und fliege
jonas lässt sich überzeugen
schließlich will er an die
weltmeisterschaft kam ein anderes ziel
gesetzt
einfach gehabt also kein urlaubsflüge
dass er die figur klappert oder
zumindest schwer barisch und ich denke
das führt unlimited schweiz ziehen wenn
man das kind erreichen
in einer woche ist es soweit
titel hin oder her jonas will sein
bestes zeigen
[Musik]
und nächste woche bei schweizer helden
der lüfte
verheerendes chaos kurz vor der
sonnenfinsternis
[Musik]
pauli
jonas erlebt an der
schweizermeisterschaft eine große
überraschung
dominik und sascha jahren endlich einem
echten tornado hinterher
mission pilot daniel besucht seine
patienten im spital und mischa und
christian machen sich auf eine lange
reise über den atlantik
[Musik]